the British pound touches a record low
against the dollar as investors make
known their displeasure over London's
big spending plans even a reassurance by
the bank of England hasn't helped
it's been a volatile year for currencies
ask anyone holding Yen rubles or Euros
even Bitcoins
but that's not the value of a
cryptocurrency that you're about to see
here it's the British pound
which fell Monday to a record low
against the dollar it's the market
reaction to the so-called mini budget
put forward by the new conservative
government at the end of last week which
included some of the biggest tax cut tax
cuts in 50 years now investors are not
happy and that's pushing up the cost of
government borrowing to recent highs
now the bank of England even weighed in
saying it's monitoring the developments
in the financial market and would not
hesitate to change interest rates by as
much as needed
but even those remarks haven't taken
pressure off of the pounds
a public opinion in the UK has meanwhile
been divided there's widespread concern
over inflation and the rising costs of
living but whether tax cuts will bring
about a change of Fortunes for average
Brits as conservatives promise has been
met with skepticism
on the streets of the city of London
Britain's Financial Center the
plummeting pound is a cause for concern
about what the coming months might bring
this is the problem right you know you
take a labor government would take go
down the spending route does that
actually generate growth does that take
out as a recession the conservative
route is always going to take you to tax
cuts and use that so that the public has
got more money to spend I think the
problem is what data is there to
actually say whether one of those is
going to be successful I don't think
there is so it is a gamble how well do
we add to it it's disappointed about the
move or have no confidence in British
economy so my impression is negative
somehow overall yeah I think it's
obvious that there's some sort of
recession coming right if it's not
already here
um we'll just have to work through it I
think
arguably you have to keep spending but I
suspect the impact is going to be fairly
disastrous Imports are obviously going
to go up in price exports are going
exporting is going to be more difficult
added to that the effects of brexit
which are coming down the down the line
straight for us and I think we're going
to be in serious trouble over the next
couple of years I've been here four
weeks so the exchange in the change in
exchange rate is around about five
percent so I get five percent more
enables me to buy another pine
all right so not everyone disappointed
by the plummeting pound Kai neufeld is
head of forecasting at the center for
economics and business research in
London Kai you had predicted a bumpy
ride in the markets after this plan was
announced the pound is now flirting with
a record low against the dollar recent
comments by the bank of England don't
seem to be having much of an effect how
serious is what we're seeing
yeah it is certainly quite a serious
situation for the government and the
bank of England I think um you know the
mini budget wasn't really that many at
all it was one of the biggest fiscal
events in in recent history really and
markets haven't taken too kindly on the
very large and you know predominantly
unfunded tax cuts that the Chandler has
announced without any assessment by the
independent forecasts at the obr
looking just at this immediate effect
what we've seen today and a bit on
Friday as well what will a weaker pound
mean for this economy that's fighting
record inflation
yeah it comes at the worst possible time
really because the pound has already
been weakening the bank of England was
battling really an uphill battle against
inflation against Rising yields on
yields so to have this added pressure
now which is coming from you know the
policy announcements on Friday is is
really the worst of times because the
only thing you know that the bank of
England can do and what markets are
pricing in already is to raise interest
rates by more and go higher and perhaps
go in in bigger steps but of course that
will lead to a lot of pain in the
economy that will slow growth it will
make borrowing more expensive and in
particular in the mortgage Market is
where we see a lot of you know a danger
building up as you know people need to
spend more and more for their mortgages
you just mentioned this not so many many
budget do you see a coherent government
policy here on the one hand capping
Energy prices driving much of inflation
on the other hand attempting to crank up
economic output
yeah I mean there's really a disconnect
between monetary policy and fiscal
policy that's the that's the big
dichotomy here you see that the bank of
England is trying to bring supply and
demand back into balance by raising
interest rates by fighting the
inflationary Peak that we're seeing at
the moment on the other hand you have
you know a government that is really you
know ripping up the fiscal rule book
really and and saying you know we need
to go for growth
um growth is the only variable the only
indicator really that the chancellor
seems interested in along with
productivity and and this creates you
know a lot of a lot of um you know
distortions and it's it's really just
not a good timing you know if they had
waited another month for the obr to do
their forecast I think a lot of the pain
could have been avoided
does this idea of growing out of
inflation make sense
I mean
yes you know growth is
still a bullet if you so like but how do
you get growth that is that is the group
The crucial uh question so
um growth is why we can you know afford
to have these high amounts of government
debt that you know most economies have
accumulated during the pandemic and also
now with the uh with the energy crisis
we do need growth and it's also to a
certain extent right that the government
focuses on growth and does things to
improve the supply side of the economy
however you know during these times
during the current energy crisis that we
have
um you know the inflationary Spike the
slide in the pound this is all not
helping the growth Outlook um in the in
the short term we do predict you know
some some benefits in the medium to
longer term to materialize but that is
going to take you know five six seven
years really to to come through and in
the meantime we do have to deal with
that weaker pound higher inflation
higher interest rates
Kai noifield at the center for economics
and business research in London thank
you very much
thank you